jetzt haben wir gewissheit was für
kaliber nach deutschland eingereist sind
aus afghanistan sie merken es fällt mir
nicht besonders leicht darüber zu
sprechen denn es ein kinderschänder und
vergewaltiger nach deutschland
eingereist weit über 200 menschen fielen
die papiere
das darf und kann natürlich nicht sein
ich möchte ihn gerne ein beispiel
vorlesen wer eingereist ist aus
afghanistan und zwar ist es saada
mohammed der wegen sexuellen missbrauchs
von kindern in deutschland zu acht
jahren verurteilt wurde 2009 10 wurde er
nach afghanistan abgeschoben und jetzt
ist er wieder zurück ein zweites
beispiel was wir in bild auch zeigen
abdrucken die steckbriefe o mat es erst
im februar abgeschoben vorurteil gegen
sexuelle nötigung vergewaltigung
mich hat das erschrocken ich hatte
schockiert und ich weiß auch immer noch
nicht ganz wie ich meine stimmen dazu
eindeutig fassen was ich mich frage ist
wie kann das passieren
wie können diese menschen wieder nach
deutschland einreisen
wir haben kein flüchtlingsproblem wir
haben ein problem mit unserer inneren
sicherheit denn eigentlich hätte das
wäre diese menschen sind es ist den
frankfurtern aufgefallen dort gab es
dann diese arbeit straße wo menschen
ihre fingerabdrücke und dokumente
vorgezeigt haben die jetzt aber schon in
usbekistan sein müssen wie kann es sein
dass diese menschen hier in einreisen
wie kann es sein dass wir keine
kontrolle weil er zwischen stationen des
b getan haben ich möchte noch damit
schließen dass ich davon überzeugt bin
dass wir kein flüchtlingsproblem haben
wir haben ein problem mit der inneren
sicherheit denn wir hören auch in den
letzten tagen herzzerreißende
geschichten von menschen die nicht mehr
rauskam von verfolgten journalist in
denen wir alle bestimmt gerne asyl in
deutschland geboten hätten wie kann es
also sein dass diese männer frauen die
es benötigt hätten den platz weggenommen
haben und wie kann es sein dass unsere
regierung das zulässt das möchte ich
hier gerne diskutieren
ja und ich möchte da hinzufügen das ist
ein skandal findet das im grunde
genommen unser innenminister hier wieder
mal den feuerwehrmann und brandstifter
schon fast zugleich spielt denn ich weiß
aus zuverlässigen quellen dass es
etliche listen an menschen gibt die
humanitär eine dringende hilfe von uns
gebraucht hätten und die ausreise
wirklich verdient hätten nachdem sie
jahrelang für uns dort gearbeitet haben
nachdem sie ganz klar von den taliban
bedroht sind
und um ihr leben kämpfen müssen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen und monate und
die wurden nicht hierher gebracht es
sind flugzeuge leer hierher geflogen die
hätten mit menschen die unsere hilfe
brauchen zurückfliegen können und sie
sind auf druck der deutschen behörden
nicht hierher gebracht worden und aus
meiner sicht gehört da ganz konsequent
aufklärung denn es darf nicht sein dass
menschen die hilfe brauchen nicht
hierher kommen dafür aber solche
menschen herkommen
lena du bist eine großartige
journalistin du bist ein bestseller
autorin du hast deine standpunkte in
vielen sachen die du sehr klar
artikuliert und sehr schweres thema sehr
schwieriges thema ist auch hier zu
behandeln aber in dieser frage kommen
nicht bei dir ganz offen nicht mehr mit
ich schätze dich sehr zulässt in welchen
weil wir haben mir zusammengesetzt ja
noch am dienstag und du hast massiv
sebastian krass kritisiert der nämlich
gesagt hier kommt kein afghane mehr rein
zumindest
österreichischen populistisch das war
falsch und populistisch weil auch in
österreich die eine große afghanische
community haben mit etwa 25.000 menschen
ist vorfälle gegeben hat
vergewaltigungen morde auch die dazu
geführt haben dass die bevölkerung
gesagt hat wir wollen hier keine mehr
und er hat das populistisch aufgezogen
und zum programm gemacht jetzt
schlimm dass diese menschen hier anderen
den platz weggenommen haben aber sind
die ja in der gefahr gleiches zu tun zu
sagen hier sind vergewaltiger unterwegs
wir müssen das behält lasse mich nicht
richtig zugehört bei falls du mir also
du hast mir bestimmt zugehört wir
schätzen uns beide gegenseitig sehr aber
der punkt ist ja ich habe ja zwei mal
betont es ist kein flüchtlingsproblem es
ist ein problem der inneren sicherheit
und am ende habe ich noch mal betont
damit genau das nämlich nicht passiert
ich möchte nicht dass ein zuschauer
jetzt hierzu sieht und sagt es kommen
nur vergewaltiger und kinderschänder
nach afghanistan das möchte ich nicht
deswegen ich hoffe ich dachte ich hätte
es geschafft rüberzubringen mir ist ganz
wichtig zu sagen wir haben kein
flüchtlingsproblem ja wir haben ein
absolutes problem der inneren sicherheit
deswegen habe ich auch noch mal am ende
die geschichten erwähnt von den
verfolgten journalistin von den
ortskräfte die natürlich politisches
asyl brauchen dies auch bekommen sollen
und was mich bei sebastian kurz zerstört
habe ich gehofft heute geschafft zu
haben wir dürfen nicht schwarz weiß
denken genauso falsch ist zu sagen wir
dürfen niemanden aufnehmen genau so
falsch ist es aber auch diese fälle zu
verschweigen ich finde wir müssen in
meine lösung wäre in usbekistan in
afghanistan hätte das glaube ich gar
nicht erfolgen können da war so ein
chaos ich weiß nicht ob da eine arbeits
straße funktioniert hätte aber der
zwischenstation usbekistan da bin ich
der festen überzeugung hätten wir eine
arbeit straße gebraucht die es ja auch
dann gibt hier wie hier in frankfurt wo
ein spezielles steht ja auf die
dokumente achtet einer überprüft die
fingerabdrücke aber ich habe für
niemanden verständnis natürlich nicht
der jemand der schon abgeschoben ist
wieder hier rein fliegen lässt da
versagt unser system trotzdem bin ich
dafür dass wir flüchtlinge aufnehmen
aber nicht kinderschänder und
vergewaltiger
aber da muss ich sagen ist in mein
eingangs statement wollte misslungen
weil das war mir natürlich wichtig
rüberzubringen ist es wichtig zu
erwähnen wenn du das ist sehr klar
ja manchmal brauchen einen zweiten
verlauf wie siehst du uns denn sana ja
also ich stimme dir da absolut zu hier
sind fehler passiert hier müsste hätte
mehr kontrolliert werden müssen aber die
frage ist natürlich auch jetzt in die
zukunft blicken wie wie und mit wem
verhindern wir genau solche fehler so
viel ich weiß ist es auch eine
angelegenheit von unserem vizekanzler
und er hat bis dato nichts dazu gesagt
da würde ich mir auch eine aussage
wünschen von ihm dass so etwas nicht
passiert weil klar ist kinder
vergewaltiger sender wollen wir hier bei
uns in deutschland nicht haben obwohl
man natürlich hier sagen dass urlaub
stolz ist unser finanzminister da gibt
es jetzt natürlich andere ämter die
zuerst was sagen müssen aber ich geb dir
natürlich recht er hätte auch was sagen
könnte ich vielleicht ist aber am
allerwichtigsten für mich ist am
allerwichtigsten die frage und die hat
sich noch nie für mich beantwortet wie
kann sowas verhindert werden weil ich
habe natürlich denn heute angerufen den
den er redakteur reporter der ist ja
auch recherchiert hat nikolaus harbusch
ich habe eben mit ihm telefoniert vor
der sendung und habe mich gefragt warum
wird das denn nicht einfach in das big
star gemacht diese arbeit straße das ist
ja eigentlich ein ganz zwingende punkt
wieso machen wir es nicht in usbekistan
direkt vor ort und überprüfen da die
menschen dann würde es ja nicht
passieren
das problem ist anscheinend aber
eigentlich dass deutschland diese
menschen dann auch nicht in usbekistan
lassen will aber da muss ich ehrlich
sagen wir können jedoch nicht noch
weiter fliegen die arbeit straße muss ja
vor ort sein aber judith was hättest du
dir denn gewünscht oder was war deine
meinung dazu wir müssen wenn ich alle
zustimmt vielleicht sagst du auch wir
sollten niemanden nehmen diese weise
sehr kurz sagt das darf man auch hier
sagen ja also jeder darf seine meinung
sagen
dann also ich glaube wie du schon gesagt
ich glaube das ist ein verwaltungs
problemen oder und ich sehe zwei ebenen
also ich glaube wenn man
versucht flüchtlinge einzufliegen aus
afghanistan ist es natürlich schwierig
bei dem ganzen chaos das passt geschehen
ist zu konstruieren die identitäten die
kriminalität die schon in der
vergangenheit stattgefunden hat usw
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es ja ein sehr
großes problem prinzipiell weil auch
wenn es darum geht straftäter in
deutschland abzuschieben hast ja das
gleiche problem also wenn du flüchtlinge
hast es gibt wunderbare integrierte
familien das letzte mal war es glaube
ich eine ich weiß die nationalität nicht
mehr aber eine junge frau die wirklich
realschulabschluss gemacht hat die eine
ausbildung bekommen hat als pflegerin
und die dann über nacht mit ihrer
familie nach rumänien abgeschoben hat
obwohl sie nicht mal wurde obwohl sie
nicht mal rumänische 16 also wieso
werden solche leute abgeschoben aber
straftäter auch sexualstraftäter
schaffen es dann immer wieder diese
sollten aus den ja beide ab
zurück zu kommen oder daneben die
behörden dann gehen austricksen dass sie
überhaupt nicht abgeschoben werden weil
die haben nämlich einfach davor ab und
da muss man sich wirklich die frage
stellen wieso passiert da in der
innenpolitik nichtwähler du warst
regierungssprecher du bist ja sehr an
einer politik gewesen der sehr viel
ahnung davon wie kannst du uns ist dann
erklären warum passiert das wieder ist
völlig legal geld schuldete ein
innenminister für die ganzen sieben
jahre der sehr auf hart auf innere
sicherheit gesetzt hat das war otto
schily der hat das durchgesetzt auch zum
zur kritik von einigen spd-linken oder
anderen linken die es gegeben hat und
als sehr auf diese innere sicherheit
gesetzt und
insofern gab es natürlich auch damals
vorfeld die zu kritisieren waren aber er
hat innere sicherheit im als
kernanliegen der bevölkerung angesehen
auch gerd schröder weil er wusste
bereich ist kann sich schützen aber wenn
nicht so viele mittel hat der muss
geschützt werden auch vom staat und das
muss die linie seien in jedem fall egal
woher der straftäter kommt heroin sie
haben ja auch eine sehr selbst sehr
bewegende geschichte die ich ihn nachher
die konnte man ja nach wie kann man
überall nachlesen
ihre meinung ist natürlich sehr spannend
dazu wie man vielleicht auch flüchtlinge
besser integrieren kann und weil wir das
muss man immer wieder feststellen wenn
sie sind sie ein paradebeispiel dafür
wird man wahrscheinlich gerne als das
bezeichnet ein paradebeispiel dafür dass
wer integration brauchen ja ich glaube
dass grundsätzlich in allen menschen ein
potenzial steckt unabhängig von ihrer
herkunft unabhängig von ihrer religion
und hautfarbe und ähnlichem was nicht
mehr wünsche ist dass wir in deutschland
das thema immer mal ernst nähmen wie so
viele andere themen auch wir fördern und
fordern wenn meine philosophie also ich
glaube dass jeder der zu gast erst mal
hierherkommt froh ist dass er bei uns
hiermit ging's ja genauso wie in
deutschland
jahrelang hände kommen also unbedingt
auch ungefährdet minderjähriger
flüchtlinge im jahr 1985 je nach berlin
bin ich gekommen und ich glaube dass die
aufgeschlossenheit zur integration in
den ersten monaten und vielleicht auch
das erste jahr sehr groß ist wenn wir
aber die menschen in ghetto ähnlichen
flüchtlingsheimen
unterbringen wie sollen die sich denn
hier integrieren wie sollen die denn
hier anschluss finden und da müssen wir
uns tatsächlich die frage stellen ob
unsere integrationspolitik sowie sie in
den letzten jahrzehnten stattgefunden
hat der richtige weg ist um tatsächlich
auch aus den menschen ihre potenziale
für dieses land nützlich zu machen eine
win win situation zu schaffen überall wo
wir hinschauen filz an fachkräften ich
habe bekannte die restaurantketten haben
die sagen ich habe 500 offene stellen
bringen mir alle die du kennst aus dem
ausland ich stelle sie sofort ein im
hotelgewerbe überall ist es gleich das
heißt wir brauchen die menschen ja hier
bei uns es sind ja viele jobs und
tätigkeiten die sie gerne machen würde
und die wir auch brauchen
aber es fehlt irgendwo an einer
progressiven auf geschlossenen haltung
gegenüber den menschen die zu uns kommen
aus meiner sicht ist noch so ein
bisschen
zurückgeblieben ja und ich wünsche mir
eine offene gesellschaft ich wünsche mir
eine offene
weine chancengerechtigkeit für alle die
zu uns kommen denn die haben es verdient
und auf der anderen seite stellen wir
uns mal in deren situation hinein keiner
verlässt seine heimat freiwillig ja also
es ist ja nicht so dass die menschen auf
einmal morgens aufstehen und sagen ich
geh jetzt nach deutschland sondern sie
sind bedroht von was auch immer und
verlassen ihre heimat und das land hier
hat auch schon einige kriege erlebt und
ich glaube dass auch von hier aus sehr
viele flüchtlinge in anderen ländern
gegangen sind und auch wir können dazu
beitragen dass wir anderen menschen die
unsere hilfe brauchen die auch erhalten
aber auf eine art und weise die menschen
würdig ist und auf eine art und weise
die auch unserem lande einen nutzen
bringt da muss ich kurz widersprechen
dass nur kurz weil die haben mir jedes
thema muss heute vorgaben also ich
glaube nicht dass die mitarbeiter zum
beispiel in flüchtlingsunterkünften also
wirklich die sozialarbeiter die sich um
die menschen kümmern nicht tief genug
sind also es ist ja fakt der größte teil
der flüchtlinge die nach deutschland
kommen sind total integrationswillig und
versuchen sich zu integrieren und sind
natürlich keine straftäter aber ich
glaube bei dieser kleinen minderheit zb
von afghanen oder syrern die nach
deutschland kommt ein fatales frauenbild
mitbringt in deren augen sind frauen
einfach weniger wert und dann
straffällig werden dass man bei diesen
klassen menschen die so ticken da hilft
überhaupt gar nichts mehr glaube ich und
da finde ich halt auch von der politik
und auch für ein foto posieren politik
oder von den linken parteien hat man
auch angst dass man ganz konsequent sagt
okay wenn wir vor allem männer die sehr
radikal islamische geschickt sind dass
man dann angst hat zu sagen die müssen
dann eben wieder gehen oder vielleicht
ja auch nicht dass zulegen vorwurf den
linken parteien machst ich bin jetzt
spricht der linken parteien wo angela
merkel die bundeskanzlerin dass all das
aber auch ist der rechten oder soja
diejenigen die verantwortlich war für
die größte öffnung gegenüber
flüchtlinge aus dem arabischen raum die
wir jemals hatten in deutschland erwägt
aber die cdu insgesamt positioniert sich
an dies war die zeit von roland koch
aber ließ lange vorbei
[Musik]